Okay, I think we are going to get started.
Thank you, everyone, for coming to the NCI sponsor session
titled "From Data Commons to Knowledge Engine: AI Enablement
Across CRDC and CCDI."
So today, we have three different talks that we will be
presenting to you today. So our first speaker is Dr.
Tania Davisson.
Dr. Tania Davisson serves as the chief of the
Data Ecosystems Branch at the NCI Center for
Biomedical Informatics and Information Technology, short CBIIT,
where she leads the Center
for the Cancer Research Data Commons, which is a powerful infrastructure
that shares NCI-funded data for secondary reuse,
encompassing the Data Commons framework, NCI cloud resources,
as well as seven specialized data commons.
So her expertise spans cancer biology, large-scale
genomic data analysis, biological databases, and cloud
applications. So over the course of her career, Dr.
Davisson has played an integral role in some of the most impactful cancer
research programs of our lifetime, which
includes the Cancer Genome Atlas, the TARGET Initiative,
as well as the Human Tumor Atlas Network.
These efforts have fundamentally shaped how we understand and study
cancer at the molecular level.
So she will be presenting to you today our
NCI's
Cancer Research Data Commons, in short CRDC, an infrastructure to
support cancer data sharing and analysis.
Then our second speaker, Dr. Subhashini Jagu,
who serves as the branch chief in NCI's Office
of Data Sharing, where she provides scientific and programmatic
leadership for some of the institute's most important data-sharing
initiatives, including the Childhood Cancer Data Initiative.
Her work centers on building the interoperable resources
and using these data coming from
CCDI and others, and strategies that's needed
to federate and integrate childhood cancer data while also guiding
researchers on helping data deposition, access, and reuse across
both pediatric and adult cancer studies.
So Dr. Jagu brings to this role more than 25 years
of research experience, a portfolio of over 30 peer-reviewed
publications, and a patent, a testament to the breadth and depth of her
contribution to the field. So today, she will be presenting CCDI
Data Ecosystem: Advancing Pediatric Cancer Research.
The last talk will be presented by me, covering an overview of
the ARPA-H BDF tool integration with CRDC.
So with that, I will pass the baton to our first presenter, Dr.
Davisson.
Thank you.
And I noticed Erica didn't actually introduce herself,
so
all right.
And I'll just say Erica is a member of my team. Dr.
Kim's a member of my team, and she's been really, really important to us
for this ARPA-H BDF integrate-- Well, the
ARPA-H project itself. So she's going to tell you more about that
a little bit later.
All right. So I'm going to introduce today our Cancer Research Data
Commons or the CRDC. I'm going to just at a very high
level give you an overview of the CRDC,
and then Dr. Jagu and Dr. Kim will be
giving you some examples and details
of how we currently use the
CRDC and how it supports programs like CCDI and then
what we're planning on doing with integration of BDF tools in the future.
So first, the Cancer Research Data Commons.
Our goal here is to be NCI's primary data platform for
cancer research. We encompass seven different data
commons, most of which are data-type specific.
We also have a centralized infrastructure and cloud
capabilities that all of our data commons rely upon,
including a Data Commons Framework that allows us
modular components that we can reuse across the CRDC.
A Cancer Data Aggregator, which aggregates the data from our seven
data commons and allows you to search using an API across all the
datasets.
And a Seven Bridges Cancer Genomics Cloud, which we also call our
NCI Cloud Resource. This provides a cloud environment for
folks to analyze the data within the CRDC as well as
data that you bring into your own personal workspaces,
allowing you to analyze the data without having to download it.
In addition, we have a Data Hub, which encompasses a data submission
portal for centralized submission of our datasets
going into the Data Commons. And in the future, we'll have a Data
Access Portal, and Dr. Kim will be talking much more about that.
We'll be integrating one of the ARPA-H tools built under the
BDF
ARPA-H program to serve as an
AI-based data access portal across the CRDC.
All of these data commons and infrastructure and cloud capabilities support our
user community. All of our data is in secure
data storage and providing access to our
varied community.
Of course, our goal for the Cancer Research Data Commons is to make the data that's
been either generated by or funded to be
generated by NCI findable with faceted
search and keyword search,
accessibleWith online analysis and
visualization tools, interoperable with standardized
APIs, standardized metadata, and incorporating other
standards like GA4GH
and reusable, so that our rich metadata and scientific
data is
used for secondary sharing.
We host data sets from many programs across,
supported by NCI, including the Human Tumor Atlas Network,
the Cancer Genome Atlas, CPTAC, Project Genie,
as well as NCI-funded grants and NCI's intramural
research, as well as our Childhood Cancer Data Initiative, or
CCDI data, which Subhashini will be talking about
next.
So just a few statistics across the CRDC.
We have 533 studies represented in our
seven data commons, over 200,000
subjects, and over 17 petabytes of data and
growing very quickly.
Within our cloud resource, we have over 1,600
years of compute have been
computed within the cloud resource since the
platform started about 10 years ago, and we offer more than
1.2 thousand public tools and workflows in that
cloud resource. We have over 100,000 users per month
and over 47,000
citations for data within PubMed.
So talking a little bit more in depth about the seven data commons that we
have. First, our largest and
oldest
data commons is our Genomic Data Commons.
This was built originally to store the genomic data from the TCGA
program,
but now encompasses many more programs as well.
What makes the Genomic Data Commons really special is that all of the data that
goes into the GDC is harmonized to the same human genome standard,
and there's a singular
pipeline for variant calling that's performed across all the data in the
GDC. So it really allows you to compare apples to apples.
We also have our Proteomics Data Commons, which stores data from CPTAC,
including the proteomic data associated with the TCGA genomic
data in the GDC.
We have our Imaging Data Commons that stores medical DICOM
images. And again,
some of the images within the IDC are from the same TCGA
patients that are represented both in the Genomic and Proteomics Data Commons.
We have an integrated Canine Data Commons that holds clinical trial
data for dogs in the community.
We have a Clinical and Translational Data Commons that holds clinical trial data
from humans.
Our newest data commons is our Population Science Data Commons,
which has just been released in the last month.
And finally, we have a General Commons.
So our General Commons, as the name indicates,
takes in data that's not otherwise appropriate for one of the other data
commons that's available. For example, our Genomic Data
Commons,
because of the harmonization step associated with the
GDC, not all genomic data generated by NCI or funded
by
NCI can be stored in the GDC. So if
the genomic data cannot be stored there, we will store it in our General Commons.
General Commons will also take data that
just has no other home.
Switching over to our infrastructure pieces, we have the Data Commons Framework,
which provides a reusable, expandable framework and modular
components that, again, we can reuse.
So some examples include Fence, which is our centralized
authentication
and authorization across the CRDC.
So much of our data is controlled access data, so we have
to make sure that the folks trying to access the data are approved.
We also have IndexD, which provides centralized indexing, and we
rely on a GA4GH standard called DRSS.
And finally, our DCF provides cloud storage for
data that is not already stored in
Amazon. Because we do offer our cloud resource, we have to have all
of our data on the cloud in Amazon. So if a data set,
for example, GDC, is not stored already in
Amazon, we replicate the data there so that all of the data across the
CRDC is available
for our NCI cloud resource.
The goal here is to democratize access to cancer research.
So not everyone has the ability to download 17
petabytes of data and analyze that data
locally. So within our NCI cloud resource, we allow
access to all 17 petabytes of our data without having to
download or move the data.
We also have workspaces, analysis tools, and workflow pipelines that
you can utilize.
In addition to that, you can bring your own tools and data
and analyze your data right alongside the data that we
have stored in the CRDC. You can also share your
workspace with your colleagues, which allows you to do collaborative
pre-publication workspaces so that you guys aren't having to, for
example, email results to each other.
And finally, we do have funds to get you started as a new user
between $300 and $10,000, allowing you
to start working with the cloud resource without any
financial
burden.In
addition, we have some interoperability projects.
The challenge, of course, that we have here, because we do have seven
data commons and data from projects like TCGA are
stored in multiple commons. For example, the genomic data in the
GDC, proteomic in the PDC, and the imaging in the IDC.
If you want to do analysis across
multiple of those data sets for the same program
for doing integrative analysis, we have this challenge.
So some of the things that we do in order to allow you to more easily
access the data across our CRDC, we have data standard
services which provide semantic harmonization, a shared data model
across the CRDC where we try and leverage any existing
standards. And we have the Cancer Data Aggregator or CDA,
which provides an API layer for query and aggregation of data
across the CRDC, so you can search across all
TCGA data sets in all of our data
commons.
We also participate in a program called NCPI or the NIH Cloud
Platform for Interoperability, where we allow you access
a greater data ecosystem. So much like the CRDC,
many of the other platforms hosted by NIH
institutes and centers
are also cloud-based. So NHGRI's AnVIL,
the Common Fund's Kids First program,
NHLBI's BioData Catalyst, and NCBI's Sequence
Read Archive all also store their data in the cloud.
We formed the NCPI program to allow us to, again, have
standards across all of these data sets that allow you to
access not only the data in our cloud workspace for the
CRDC, but also the data stored in SRA, in
AnVIL, in BioData Catalyst, and in Kids First.
Finally, I'll just finish up mentioning our CRDC data portals.
I mentioned our CRDC data hub earlier.
It's the same
concept here. So
because we have seven different data commons, we need a standard
place to submit the data across the CRDC to
lower the barrier for
submitting data,
just to make it easier for our data submitters.
So we have a data submission dashboard that allows you to
interact with the CRDC
and submit your data in one place. This is a work in progress.
There are still some of our data commons that have not yet been incorporated into
the single data submission platform, but we're working towards
that.
Finally, we're working towards a data discovery dashboard
that will provide access to visualization and
search in a graphical user interface
across all the CRDC data. And
Erica's going to talk a little bit more about that because we're going to leverage
one of the tools that ARPA-H funded in the BDF program
to make this data discovery dashboard.
And that's it for me, so thank you for listening.
Next up, we're going to have Dr. Jegu, and she's going to talk more
about how the Childhood Cancer Data Initiative
leverages CRDC platform.
Okay.
Thank you, Tanya. Good morning, everyone.
I'm going to provide a very high-level overview on how
CCDI is building on the power of data community
to transform the childhood cancer research.
So the main goals of the CCDI are to gather and integrate data from every
child or AYA diagnosed with a pediatric cancer, and
create a national strategy of molecular characterization to inform
diagnosis and treatment. And the most importantly, to develop a
platform or tools to bring together clinical
research and registry, all of those together.
As I mentioned,
the CCDI data ecosystem or building a platform is one of the
central goal of the CCDI. This ecosystem
gathers all the data or connects the tools and resources
so that all the data like clinical or research or
registry data are connected to help building
and also to improve the patient outcomes.
Tanya touched on the infrastructure, but I'm going to walk through the various
resources we provide to the community to help
using the data we have been collecting or analyzing the data.
So I'll start with the Explore dashboard.
The foundation for this Explore dashboard is having a data model.
And it's essential because we make sure that the data
collected is harmonized across the data sets so
there is a consistency and also the
interoperability between the data sets.
And then once the users come in and build the cohorts of their interest, they
can take the data into the Cancer Genomics Cloud, which Tanya just
mentioned, and analyze the data using the tools that are
already provided by CGC or bring your own tools to analyze the
data.
We are also making the data available through the visualization tools
like GDC and cBioPortal, so it helps the
non-bioinformaticians too, because it's hard to analyze those large volumes of
data. And then I'll be going into the details of the cBioPortal in a
minute. And then we have developed our APIs, like the
Federation API is how we refer. It helps in searching
the data, not only that is hosted in NIH repositories,
but also that is not part of the NIH repositories.
We have a pilot, and I will also be showing a couple of slides on that.
And then the most important thing is the Childhood Participant Index
API. This API helps in mapping the data that is
collected across various projects or time
pointsAnd then most importantly, we have the clinical
data
resources like C3DC and also the pediatric version of the
surveillance data, which is NCCR.
And the most commonly used resource is the Childhood Cancer Data Catalog
because it compiles all the resources that are available
across the globe in one place, so users can quickly
find the data of their interest or the resources or tools of their
interest that are associated with the pediatric cancer research.
So CCDI Hub is the entry point to access all these tools and
resources. I provided a snapshot of Explore dashboard here.
Users can come and build the cohorts of their interest with the various
filters we provide on the site.
Currently, CCDI ecosystem has 41 data sets.
Just to name a few, we have data from Childhood Cancer Survival Study, Pediatric
MATCH,
the PBAT Consortium, and so on. And it's still
growing. We'll be adding more data as we get them into the
ecosystem.
I'll be touching on one of the major data sets that is available
through the CCDI ecosystem that is coming in from the Molecular Characterization
Initiative. It's a partnership between NCI and Children's
Oncology Group, and we leverage their Project Every Child protocol
to enroll the patients on this protocol.
It provides state-of-the-art molecular characterization
to patients at no cost to
them. And the results are usually returned within
21 days. And so far, we have more than 9,000 patients
enrolled on this protocol, and it's still an active protocol.
And after the molecular characterization is done for the clinical
testing purposes, the remaining samples are stored,
and then we also do some research characterization like whole
genome sequencing, RNA sequencing on the leftover
samples.
There are also a couple of studies that are following these patients
longitudinally to analyze the germline
abnormalities and also cascade testing in unaffected immediate family
members.
So the table shown on this slide summarizes the
enrollment by disease subtype, and a map on the
right side shows the enrollment by state.
And I quickly
summarized various assays performed in the clinical testing space,
and also the file formats that are being
generated out of these clinical assays being submitted to the CCDI ecosystem.
I thought it's important to walk through the flow in terms of how we collect the
data that is being generated here.
So the patients that are enrolled on Project Every Child
will also be consenting to the MCI protocol.
Once they consent to the MCI protocol, the specimens that are
extracted from the patients are shipped to the biopathology center,
and they extract the nucleic acids and send them to the clinical
sequencing that is conducted at the Nationwide Children's Hospital as well.
And as I said, there are various assays that are being performed, like exome
sequencing, Archer fusion, methylation.
So once the clinical testing is done,
the reports are returned to the physicians within 20 days.
But then the de-identified reports are also submitted to the
CCDI data ecosystem.
BPC is also submitting the pathology slides to the CCDI,
and then we also collect the clinical data from COG, and all
of them are integrated in the CCDI ecosystem.
Tanja again touched on the various infrastructure components.
We leverage a lot of the CRDC resources to store this data.
And I provided links here too in terms of how to access the
data and also the dbGaP accession number to submit a
request to us, because some of this data is in controlled access space.
And then
we are also making this data
available through GDC or cBioPortal.
I'm going to walk through how this can be visualized in the CCDI's
instance of the cBioPortal.
So,
the pathology slides that are collected from this protocol are made available
through the Imaging Data Commons.
So far, we have more than 4,000 images.
We also have a collaboration with
DOE, and they have processed these images and made them
AI-ready. So anybody interested in training AI models
or testing their models, please feel free to use these
images. They're all open access and available through the Imaging Data
Commons.
Because we have a large volume of data coming in from programs
like MCI or Pediatric MATCH, we want to make sure that this data is
available to the researchers that do not have bioinformatics experience.
I just highlighted a use case here.
For example, a researcher who wants to create a cohort of
rhabdomyosarcoma with a fusion gene,
they can come and search in the cBioPortal.
I'm sure many of you are aware of cBioPortal.
And most importantly, the clinician or
tumor boards, if they want to find the patients of their interest,
for example, a patient like mine, they can come to the cBioPortal and
mine for those particular mutations or
genes of their interest.
So I provided a quick snapshot of
the data that is being just released last week from the MCI
program. We have so far 6,000 patients'
data associated with MCI released in cBioPortal.
We are continuously analyzing the data and making them available through
the cBioPortal again. So this shows the breadth of
the clinical and genomic data, and they're all combined and in one place so
that users that do not have bioinformatic experience
can come and analyze the data easily
here.I am just quickly
highlighting here how SNV data associated with the clinical significance,
because in the clinical reports, they have various tiers
based on the guidelines provided by AMP and ASCO.
So it's hard for the users to go through all those thousands of
clinical reports provided in the PDF or JSON format.
So we made that part easy for downstream users by extracting them
and making them available through the cBioPortal.
We also extracted the methylation data from the clinical
reports and have incorporated that in the cBioPortal as a
separate widget. So if you
are interested in a particular disease type and fusion genes, you can
search for it, and the widget clearly shows the number of
patients in a separate
tabular column. And you can also find the fusion genes
associated with it because we also do the Alta fusion
analysis. This provides the granular details compared to what we
have sometimes in the CRF, so it helps in
further downstream analysis.
Because NCI is such a valuable and national resource,
we do want to follow these patients longitudinally.
So NCI just launched an observational
study that is referred as
Pediatric and AYA Rare Cancer Study.
The primary goals of this study is to develop a registry that
contains a core data set on all rare cancer participants,
and also collect all real-world data that can help in informing
the clinical trial enrollment. And
most importantly, the data that is being collected through this
protocol will also be shared through the CCDI data
ecosystem.
I would like to quickly summarize or
touch on this pediatric version of the surveillance data that
is made available through the National Childhood Cancer Registry.
It's a rapidly growing
resource, and it covers more than 70% of the population.
It has three different types of accesses.
NCCR Explorer is an open access portal.
It provides the aggregate or summary level statistics,
whereas NCCR data in CSstat, it is a registered
access. Once you register, it gives you or provides you the
software to analyze the data and visualize, for example,
rates or frequencies, those type of things.
And then the NCCR data platform, it was released a year ago.
It is a controlled access platform.
It provides the data at the individual level that is linked to the
various longitudinal resources.
Because of the risk for re-identification is high in these type of
platforms, we have to keep the data in the controlled access, and the website
clearly documents all the processes in terms of
requesting an access to this data.
And then I mentioned on one of my first slides that
we have developed an API, which is referred as a CPI,
CCDI Participant Index. It's a digital ID mapping and matching
reference. What happens is we collect all the research IDs
associated with the participant known to the submitter at the time of
submission, and we try to connect the data that is collected
at various time points or through various projects or different
data types. Currently, we have more than 400,000
IDs, and we are mapping them across the
domains, and they're all listed on our website.
If you have any questions, please feel free to follow up with us.
And I provided a quick use case here.
Users can map the patient and sample
data across CCDI, NCI data with the rich institutional
EHR data, too. So that will be one of the powerful use case
for the CPI. And also to connect with the data in NCCR
data platform, too. So what we are doing is we are
using the CPI to connect the data, like for example, the genomics
data in the CCDI ecosystem with the real-world
clinical data in the NCCR data platform.
So we have this API, which helps in searching the data not only that is
hosted in NIH repositories, but also outside
NIH repositories like Treehouse, Cenchid Cloud, and
several others joined voluntarily after the pilot phase because they want
to make their data available or searchable through this API so
that the visibility of the data increases, and they can have more
collaborations as well. If any of you are interested in joining this,
please reach out to us at the email provided here.
And we also provided a very clear documentation in our GitHub
repositories, but we are always happy to help to make this
happen for you.
And this is quickly summarizing that our intention is to serve
all types of users. We have developed various resources and tools to
serve the community.
And we have had a lot of visitors coming in, and we would like to
get your feedback to improve the various resources we
are providing. We just published and highlighted topic last
week, which summarizes the various topics of
interest for the CCDI, and I want to provide a quick
plug-in here. I also have a poster presentation this afternoon from 2:00 to
5:00. Please stop by to ask any questions or if
you would like to discuss on any other specific topic.
With that, I think I have all the resources summarized here.
I believe these slides are made available.
Again, please stop by at the poster if you have any questions.
If you would like to engage with us, subscribe to our newsletter, and for
questions or feedback, contact us at the
CCDI mailbox. That's all. Thank you.
Erica, over to you now.
We have a lot of time.
Okay.
Okay, great. So I intentionally skipped an intro to myself
so I could actually do the intro here before my talk.
So I'm Erica Kim.
I am a program officer at the Center for Biomedical Informatics and
IT at the NCI,
and I also have a dual appointment.
Currently, I am detail borrowed to another
agency within HHS, which is called Advanced Research Projects
Agency for Health, short ARPA-H, which is the newest
agency within the human health services.
So I serve as a program manager at the ARPA-H, currently
managing two different ARPA-H programs under my portfolio.
So that's why you see two logos here.
And the reason that I'm here today to give you a presentation
about the BDF tools that are being integrated with the
CRDC ecosystem is so that I can
highlight how these collaborative efforts between two different
agencies are really accelerating the use and reuse of
our NCI-funded and generated data.
So, a brief overview of the program that I lead at the ARPA-H,
which is called Biomedical Data Fabric Toolbox, and I'll in short refer
to it as a BDF Toolbox.
Actually, it was conceptualized from our NCI team.
Back then, our NCI director, Monica Bertagnolli, charged
us to find really next generation of ways
to really use our
cancer research data so that we can bring the research findings to the
clinical practice faster. So as many of you
are aware, we still have a lot of challenges where lots
of data sits in silos and they're fragmented.
So many data sits in academic research labs, clinical centers,
hospitals, and so forth. So the BDF Toolbox's
vision was to be able to really break down the silo by
providing tools that can reduce the manual effort and also
help our research community to really navigate
and how to use this
massive amount of rich research data that are made available
through such infrastructures like CRDC and many other NCI and
NIH-funded repositories. So the BDF Toolbox program
aimed to develop this type of tools for various types
of data, including electronic health records and other
associated clinical data, lots of omics and
research lab-generated data, as well as clinical trials data
and multimodal imaging data.
And lastly, the patient and caregiver input data that are
available from the real-world setting.
So in the middle is the Biomedical Data Fabric, that toolbox of sets of tools
that we have been developing since 2024.
And the goal is to make biomedical research data easier to use by
reducing the manual effort for data integration, curation, and
also by developing new data fabric capabilities and
tools, and ultimately to build this health data science model that can really be
applied to many different disciplines and have the
lasting impact.
So as I noted, the program itself is a partnership between
NCI and ARPA-H to really have that model
of ARPA, which accelerates innovation,
innovative tool development. It's an R&D technology development
agency. So leveraging their charge to bring these
tools at an accelerated pace, and then NCI would be bringing these
tools, transitioning them into our ecosystem so that we can really
speed the use of healthcare research data.
So we are starting with cancer, but the program itself is aimed to
generalize across different disease domains.
But
having our NCI collaboration as the initial partner, we
are starting with cancer and applying these tools to the cancer data
ecosystem.
So the BDF has four different technical areas and one
that is focused on system integration.
The first technical area is automated data collection.
So as I noted, we're really aiming to reduce the manual effort that goes
into harmonizing, mapping, curating, and so forth of the
data. So we want to lower barriers to high-fidelity,
timely, and automated data collection from research,
and also health record systems.
So technical area two is focused on leveraging, harnessing the power
of AI and other automated methods to help machine-assisted
curation of our research data and healthcare data.
So the technical area two is focused on helping prepare, connect,
and harmonize multi-source data.
We often represent those multi-source data as having different
dialects that we need to be translating on the spot
so that we can inform and enable analysis at
scale.
So obviously, what do you do with all this data?
You need to be able to intuitively explore them.
So our technical area three is focused on bringing
advanced AI-assisted tools to
really
make data exploration easier and
develop platforms and other
dashboards that could be used by diverse stakeholders and
decision-makers.
And so across the first three technical areas, we have
embedded a user engagement team which does evaluation of data fabric
tools as they are being developed, even from conceptual stage.
So this could be developed with the target user audience in mind.
And so we have a user engagement and testing team that's been embedded as part of
our BDF program. So that's the various technical areas
in a nutshell of the BDF program. And as I
noted, and as Tanya noted, we really want to bring these tools to help
our cancer research community to deliver knowledge and also
realize full potential of the cancer data
ecosystem.So, with my
NCI hat, I lead the data submission
portal
part of the CRDC infrastructure. So, some of
the tools that I will be highlighting in the rest of my talk will touch
on how the tools are being then integrated with the
various parts of the data hub
workflow, or how they are tangentially associated with the
cancer research data ecosystem by
leveraging those open APIs that are available for other platforms to
pull data in to then bring them into some more customized,
user-specific data dashboards.
So, one of the goal of ARPA-H program is always the success
criteria is having a successful transition partner lined up
as the ARPA-H program produces either tools
or new findings or new technologies.
So NCI is serving as one of that transition partner in order to
enhance usability of cancer research data submission,
access, and discovery by the cancer research community
who has no computational background, but also with the
computational savvy background.
So I'm going to cover various themes where we are
incorporating the tools that are being developed by the BDF
program, and I'll say we have over 50 different
tools that have been prototyped and deployed and have a different
degree of maturity that are available for the community to go and
explore. But here in this talk, I'll just highlight some of those
tools.
So for data curation, what are we doing here?
So we have a team from a small company called Netrius, led
by Mark Weston,
that's been developing a AI-assisted data curation
platform. So this BDF tool supports AI-driven
harmonization and curation using accurate, reliable large language
models for biomedical data curation.
So the team has demonstrated that it can actually,
with the real-world use cases that they have been tested with,
demonstrate at least a 90% reduction in the data curation
time that is by incorporating model-assisted
chatbot workflow. Their tools have been actually
already integrated with the Sage Bionetworks Synapse system
as Sage Bionetwork actually provides a lot of data coordination
center activities to
other NCI-funded programs. And not only can they
demonstrate reduction in time for curation of the data, they can also
demonstrate that they are able to surface more data to be now be
used. So making the data to be more AI-ready for downstream
analysis and so forth. So they
have demonstrated that their model uses three orders
magnitude fewer
parameters than the state-of-the-art language models.
So they're not just taking any frontier or other just
commercially available language models and just throwing the data
onto those models. It's really taking what's available
from LLMs, fine-tuning them with the various type of
zero-shot,
one supervised, unsupervised type of trainings and so forth, and various
approaches to show that we can reduce the manual
time, but also the cost associated with data curation.
They have developed, these are some workflows, a
DataCord user interface. So CRDC will be
making this DataCord user interface available for the data
submitters to actually go and upload their metadata and
try mapping it to a downstream target data commons, in this
case, CRDC genomic data commons, for example.
And they can actually do this curation here on the spot.
And the DataCord will give you suggestions for any metadata
that doesn't align with the genomic data commons standards,
give you confidence scores, and ask you if you want to accept
or reject those recommendations.
And what it can do is then take the user's feedback and
retrain their model, and so whatever they are gathering from the users as an
input, as this is being deployed and be used by the future
submitters, they can actually continue to learn
and update their model
so that it can help have a more accurate
models available for future submissions.
So, as I noted, their prototype has been actually
deployed within the NCI ecosystem. We are testing it right now.
If you go to this GitHub, you'll be able to get access to their
either front-end or the back-end model, so you can actually also do the
testing yourself.
So that's one data curation tool that we are integrating within the
CRDC workflow. And the back-end API
to the model will also be made available within our data submission
workflow as part of the data hub that will support data
validation and harmonization.
Okay. So the next
theme that I wanted to cover is sort of ways that we are
helping gather data across different data ecosystems.
So one tool is called Data Gatherer from New York
University. The PI is Julian Fayer.
The Data Gatherer really identifies and extracts
data sets that are referenced from scientific publications.
So oftentimes we publish papers, and there are massive
amount of supplementary data that sits with those publications.
AndThey are not easily explored or extracted
for downstream AI tools to be ingesting and using.
So this tool, actually written in Python, and it's all available on
our GitHub now,
will take those list of publications and using combined
rule-based and LLM methods, then it will process those full text
and extract information out of the metadata
out of the data sets so that they can actually be made more easily used
by downstream users. So it parses scientific articles from
open access resources like PubMed,
extracts data sets that are mentioned from structure sections in the
publication, and go and looks for those data sets that are
available and associated with those publications.
And then it links to various downstream data repositories so that
the data set can be pointed to a place where the data has
been deposited.
So a number of different
graphical representations of how they're making this data
getter possible, which is the top
graph.
But I just wanted to point out that they have two separate sort of
approaches on how they extract that metadata available around the
data set into this tool. So the first one
is RTR, retrieve then read. One method is rule-based
method where they would look for different sections within the publications, and
they point their tools to then extract information out
of those sections to understand what type of data
set they should be going after for. So that's one approach.
And the next approach is a full document read, which is another approach to
skim through the entire document without having a specific sections
parsed
a priority. And then
applying LLMs to then extract information, and then they
combine these two in order to perform that data gathering
process downstream. The bottom graph just kind of
shows how they are then extracting data that's
available from tabular Excel files, for example.
So AutoDDG is a tool that automatically analyzes
those sort of tabular data and feeds the information that is
made available from there to LLMs in order to generate
user-friendly descriptions of what's available in those tabular format
files. So a lot of ways to gather data and
help surface more information for researchers.
Another tool, and I'm going to go a little fast, that I wanted to highlight is a
biomedical imaging hub. So it was initially funded by
another IC at the NIH, at the
NIBIB Institute. So they have sort of put this
very nice data resource together that's focused on medical imaging.
So BDF actually have funded parts of their tool
development that leverages the massive amount of biomedical
imaging data that this hub makes available.
So it's a federated medical imaging data discovery platform that
provides the community with access to high-quality medical
imaging and associated data while maintaining privacy and security of
patients. So one really nice feature of the BIH
is that they automatically, any types of data that they
ingest sequesters 20% of their data for
any type of AI model validation. So they make available
80% of the data for training, leaves 20%
untouched so that people can actually perform validation on that data as
well. And they have, through the BDF program,
they have 15 different projects under
BDF, and they have developed ways that you could understand the
demographic representations from the training data to a validation
data, so you can compare and match and make sure what you're training and testing
on
have the same underlying representations.
And they are part of this data mesh that brings together many different medical
imaging platforms that include their own MIDRIC, Stanford AI,
AIMI,
Imaging Data Commons from CRDC,
TCIA, and various other imaging modalities, which also
includes NIH Clinical Center, which is a very
valuable resource for imaging data.
So just wanted to highlight that one very specific imaging-focused
integration with the CRDC is provided by MIDRIC team.
And then few ways that we are now making data
exploration more easier for our downstream researchers to be able to
navigate is through number of different chatbots or other user
interfaces. So one that I wanted to highlight is from ICF, led
by Rajesh Theggodu. They have developed this
BioInsight AI chatbot, and it's a standalone
platform that brings together a number of different
CRDC data repositories, including genomic, proteomic,
and other proteomic resources like PRIDE, proteomic exchange
data into their chatbot environment.
So they enable plain language queries of biomedical resources,
including CRDC and few other
proteomic-focused
repositories. And it gives you context-aware insights rather
than just generic responses, and they have been curated and trained on biomedical
research data. So,
the data has a UI. You can go to the GitHub,
and get access to the chatbot and explore
the alpha release of this chatbot yourself.
So another
discovery interface that I wanted to touch on is from Harvard Medical School.
So CRDC has been ingesting a lot of single-cell
modality data through our Human Tumor Network Atlas program and
others. So this team is actually making a lot of
rich resource, and deep molecular phenotypic
data at a single-cell resolution level,
into this sort of UDI interface. So how they are
doing this is they are providing a toolkit that can render discovery interface
specification in automated and interactive visual
way.By bringing together this visualization
grammar that can be used to generate many different visualizations.
So they're using these principles from grammar of graphics,
and on top of that, they are laying on a LLM
chatbot interface, an agentic framework, in order to generalize
visualization that can be done with natural language prompts.
So this is a prototype version of their interface.
They have, on the left side, a faceted sort of ways people can
continue to search and inquire and query about the data.
But based on what people are either asking or
toggling between the faceted searches,
on the right side, visualization of that data will change.
So it's just a few representations of different ways they can graph what you're
looking at, but they're right now layering a lot of other single-cell
modality visualization representations into this,
so more to come.
Sort of the last one that I wanted to touch on is
this team has been developing knowledge graphs for many different
biomedical research communities.
So we have actually charged them to leverage what they have been developing as part
of this INDRA, Integrated Network and Dynamic Reasoning Assembler,
and reach their knowledge graph with lots of cancer research
data that we have made available.
So INDRA helps researchers to generate causal and mechanistic insights.
So this is not just like a knowledge base, but it actually helps you to get to
the causality. It does it by coupling automated knowledge
extraction and assembly from literature with many different data analysis
algorithms.
So it pulls in different literature, knowledge base,
data sets, other information that's available from data
repositories, and allow you to be able to then
search across this knowledge graph, to then
ask questions so that you can understand causality of certain
mechanisms and help you develop hypothesis
generation.
So lastly, as Tania noted, we have a tool that will
now be integrated into CRDC ecosystem to serve as
our sort of CRDC data discovery portal.
The team that will be developing and further enhancing
that platform is from JadaWare.
So the
back end of this platform is the Beaker, which is an
AI-augmented notebook platform that
performs sophisticated data analysis
that's accessible to domain experts.
What it also have integrated is various AI
agents that
has been customized and trained to mine data that is available
from our CRDC Data Commons and many other data
resources they have integrated into this Beaker Hub.
So this is the current interface that we are working on making the
user interface a bit more user-intuitive and friendly.
But what's unique about this is that they are completely transparent.
Provenance is available. Every single code that has been generated based on
your query and the interaction is available for anyone who might be
computational savvy to actually go
back and make changes to those codes and have that Jupyter
environment notebook available so that you can have more,
I guess, power on
how this type of AI-assisted exploration
tools would provide value to you. So
this is a Beaker Hub, and it's currently released.
The beta version of this Beaker Hub is released to the public, so you can
go to the website on the bottom and sign up for an account and
explore it yourself. And I know in the morning there was a plenary session that
described Bi Omni, which is from a Stanford team.
So we've done a benchmarking study between the Beaker Hub and Bi Omni, and the way
the approaches to these two separate
agentic AI
interaction exploration tool is kind of different.
And so I would encourage you to also sign up for both and see
how your results to your queries may differ.
And I'm happy to deep dive in our benchmark results of the Beaker
Hub and the Bi Omni if you're interested.
So I mentioned there's a lot to cover, but I'll give you more.
So if you go to this QR code, we actually created a BDF knowledge
base that list all 50 plus tools that have been
developed from BDF program. You can go and
explore their
descriptions, the PIs who's in charge of it, but
also all the GitHub links are made available.
So, one of the main goal of the BDF was to really
produce tools that are open source, modular, that can plug and play
based on the downstream needs of the user.
So feel free to sign up for an account and explore and provide feedback.
And lastly, I wanted to give a shout-out to a upcoming Data Jamboree that
we are co-hosting between our group and ODS
CCDI team. It will be hosted at the NIH
from November 16th through 18th.
There is a project submission deadline that's coming up, which is July 1st,
and we highly encourage you to go and read the Data
Jamboree description and apply
fun projects so we can further explore how we can make more
meaningful insights out of our cancer research data that are made available.
Thank you.
We have five minutes, so happy to take any questions,
feedback, comments
for all of our talks, not just mine.
So thank you.
So I think AI is doing something that
we probably didn't predict, making infrastructure
sexy.Right.
What's not sexy yet is data curation.
As you noted here, it's still really hard.
A couple of slides you showed on AI-assisted data curation caught my eye.
Mm-hmm.
But does it require some connection to Synapse, or are
the tools-- Can you pull them out and build your own ecosystem around them?
Oh, yes. So Synapse was just one example that I wanted to
demonstrate it being deployed with an already
powerful data ecosystem that serves as a
data coordination center for many programs.
So that's one example of how these tools now can be integrated into
existing data infrastructure. We are integrating that into a CRDC
ecosystem, but also making a standalone version available
for others to be able to go and use. So
any submitter that will be depositing data to CRDC can go and test it out.
Or you can also go to their GitHub repository and pull their code
base and launch it in your ecosystem and test it out too.
So that's all different modular ways that we're making them available.
And if you have any problem, please reach out to me
or the PI, and then I'm happy to connect you.
Great. Okay.
So my name is Stephanie Sandwer. Great talk. Thank you for your time today.
I work on the St. Jude Cloud team, so I'm deeply involved in a lot of
these platforms and continuing to learn.
As he mentioned, curation and harmonization is critical for us.
We're in the AI world. We're basing our future off of the data that we have
today.
And so how do you envision scaling, specifically long term?
Because you can be in a portal, maybe IDC, and see a
diagnosis for a particular H&E slide, but then you go to a different
platform like the GitHub, explore, download the manifest.
The diagnosis might be different based on who you're getting the data from and what
type of omics data you're receiving.
So then you have to harmonize across those platforms.
And I'm not sure is your AI curation that you were
showing actually going to harmonize the data points across those
subjects and patients across the platforms?
Is the first question. The second one is what happens when the
ontologies update? Are the AI curation going to update based on that
ontology model? And then are we going to have versioning
examples? So if you update based on a new AI model, are you
going to show a new version to
allow the audience to know that it's been curated on
AI and then
on a new version? And then lastly, are you looking to use the AI
curation to retroactively update all diagnosis and
harmonizations across the CRDC?
Very great questions.
And I also want to point out if I don't have a satisfaction
to your answers, I have Umit Topaloglu, who is from NCI.
He leads our entire semantic infrastructure team.
Perfect.
So I wanted to point out that our curation tool actually also do leverage a lot of
standards that have been deeply curated.
It's not just throwing an AI on
garbage data. It's really using that
articulated, curated, rich resource that we have
access to from NCIT, caDSR,
ICD codes, Uberon, and many other
standards that are available in the community.
And for the Netrius tool, and I should have gone a little bit more and touched
more on other data curation tools that we have actually available
from BDF, but the Netrius tool, the provenance tracking is really critical
part of that tool. So as I mentioned, as a
small example, when a submitter updates
certain metadata, that this is the more accurate one than what you provided as a
recommendation, they all feed back to their training model.
And
the users will know what version of the model they are
being inferenced and used to provide the
recommended metadata.
For patient-relevant metadata
harmonization, that is focus of our phase
two of the BDF program, which is pediatric care expansion,
which will touch on dealing with a lot of the patient-level data
that's available from healthcare
and also clinical research data. So I'm happy to go into
that a bit more deeper with you separately.
And I wanted to see if you guys have any responses to the
question.
Yeah, go ahead, Tanya.
Yeah.
So, Stephanie, I think one of the point you touched on
is we have imaging data in IDC for MCI project, for
example, that doesn't display the diagnosis or other metadata there.
Now you have to go to the CCDI hub to pull the associated metadata.
We are trying to work towards...
Also, you touched on how are you going to update the metadata in
different resources. So to avoid that
duplication of efforts, we are right now displaying the metadata only in the CCDI
hub,
because that's the source of truth.
Mm-hmm.
But I
just saw recently that GDC is also incorporating the visualization
within the portal.
Mm-hmm.
So we may pull in that type of aspect, too.
It just was presented at one of Tanya's meeting.
So we are trying to explore and see if we can make the images
visualized within the hub, for example.
So you don't have to go to two different sources or resources to
gather the metadata. And then we can have as diagnosis.
I know we work closely on the ontologies or the pediatric diagnosis
categories, too, so we can update at one place, and it populates into
downstream
resources as well.
And I'll just note that that's one of the reasons why we are trying
to have a singular data submission portal and
platform for the CRDC across all of our seven data commons, because we're
definitely seeing that. You might have
different metadata associated with the same patient in the proteomics data
commons for a TCGA patient, for example, than you might find in the genomic
data commons
And so,
and one other thing I'll note that relates to both this and the first
question is when we first secured funding for both
the singular data submission portal for CRDC as
well as the future data access portal,
we didn't anticipate how the technology would really change
over the last few years,
and really, really make a huge difference in
how these ultimately are rolled out. So, yeah.
The technology's kind of overtaken our original purpose-
Mm-hmm
... but it's a good thing.
Thank you. I think one more question, and I think
we're-
We can hang around.
We can hang around. Yeah. We can hang around. Yeah.
Okay.
Thank you for providing these wonderful tools.
They look very powerful. There are many tools.
The question is, how a user will use those tools.
Can you give
some concrete example of people use this tool
to answer a good bio, or cancer, or biology-related
questions?
Mm-hmm.
This is my question.
Yeah, sure. And I can start, and then, and I'll
ask others to chime in. So one tool that we
have gotten a lot more attraction is our actually Open
Co-Scientist tool that is built
from our data access hub team,
that actually helps biologists and researchers to leverage a lot of this
knowledge graph and others that I have touched on
to generate hypothesis. So it is a tool that
folks are right now using to ask some questions, and it helps you,
and it debates with you on your hypothesis that you
are asking questions to this platform.
Any example available you can share?
Oh, I have demos. I can point you to lots of video
tutorials. But for this Co-Scientist, we have a demo that I can point you, and you
can take a look.
Okay.
And even explore it yourself.
Thank you.
Okay, and I don't know, Tania.
You good?
I think we're out of time.
Okay.
Yeah.
Great. Thank you so much. Thank you all for attending. Thank you all for coming.